a good time today Simon he looks a lot
more relaxed than what we saw yesterday
yeah he was clearly quite tired
yesterday and he's more chilled out
today
um and the games have been really
exciting and we've got a French defense
as well now so another interesting
opening no all right
the things he's really enjoying himself
today and he's actually playing like
really sharp positions and maybe it goes
back to that interview he's not
necessarily even trying to play the best
openings he's playing Just openings
which are going to lead to fun games
which is great for us yeah I think he
was just fighting his inner conscience
there Magnus yeah I think he was very
tempted to play The Exchange variation
just trading off pawns going symmetrical
going for the draw but he's aware of the
fans Magnus is very aware of what people
want to see but also he loves
entertaining himself loves chess he did
it yesterday against Fabiano he didn't
shut down the game immediately and okay
that led to some drama but
um yeah this one I'm glad to see it
Mainline classical variation of the
French right now caught up but we had to
kind of go oh great very good David
actually it was was a really good game
whereas Magnus I've seen him on both the
white and black side of this position so
maybe slightly more experience here
it's actually a blunder here I've played
this position many times black and uh
studied it a lot but castle and queen
side it was first played in morsevich
versus uh sheer off I think in this
position and uh it's actually a big
blunder because black can now play C4 uh
the main line now yeah is is to Castle
kingside but uh you've got to defend
your C Pawn First and this move well I'm
not sure about this if you need to win
you're closing it down a lot as soon as
white pushes sorry black pushes that
pawn he can't do that anymore but Magnus
now playing a very standard idea uh so
F5 very opportunistic but uh very strong
potentially he's just getting ready to
take as Ivanka mentions maybe even
castle and there's an open F line look
at where the black king is situated as
well it needs to evacuate as quickly as
possible this opening has not gone well
for for Asia it's a family as well
who've really supported him uh helped
him move to France and uh really kind of
pushed him in his career and uh it's
paid off if you think of other top
players as well you see the Young
players now is incidentally you know
David and I did commentary at Norway
chess and a lot of the players brought
their parents with them it hasn't
changed over the generations because
even wish he talks about how his mum
played a big big role in his career and
I think it was for Gary as well uh so I
wonder if that's the one thing that's a
constant family I've I've seen some
horrible things like eight-year-olds
being shouted out when they lose a game
of chest in front of loads of people and
it's like oh my God you know you want to
say something but you know it's very
hard to and those kids always give up
you know because the pressure's too much
so you've got to you've got to have the
you've got the fine line and so just
before going into tournaments they would
plan out their jokes they would plan out
topics just to get Magnus in the right
frame of mind wow which is such a
different approach from uh from what we
normally see so definitely something
that's been a big big role in becoming
the best chess band we see that across I
think Generations as well meanwhile
action is on Olivers are putting on the
fight on the queen side but will the
game get into trouble will his King come
into fire I regret this decision uh
taking with the pawn rather than at
least slightly freeing his uh French
defense Bishop I think any french
defense player wants to activate this
piece in a bad situation you might as
well try to mix it up I I figure in
general and at least that gives some
chances okay he's making the exchange on
F1 first and he's playing it I mean I
think this is this is also in early
Razor's style he he wants to keep it
sharp he wants to get some kind of
initiative he can get his Bishop to A6
never gonna happen then uh yeah it's
just never gonna happen is it okay has
this helped oh I don't know I'm looking
at the bar there has this helped at all
then the bishop disappears but I think
now your idea Ivanka uh Bishop to H5
would be winning because the White Queen
would be swooping in uh to F7 this is
really difficult for a human to spot uh
Magnus plays a far more natural move uh
he plays the move H4 somehow managed to
nearly come back yesterday but uh it's
it's nearly impossible against Magnus
he's just too good and um okay we'll see
Ali Razer taking a pawn there she looks
clever you're giving up the black queen
it looks like you're counter-attacking
winning the White Queen but after the
White Queen gives herself up oof it's
just collapsing for black no matter what
you try here you can trade off one
Bishop but this isn't going to help you
at all next move at the very minimum
this is threatened the pawn Center has
collapsed and Magnus has indeed gone for
that move in game two it's a very
difficult situation to come out of
psychologically as well and you have to
play black and a must-win situation you
tend to take these decisions that you
normally wouldn't otherwise and it's all
gone wrong the age for Pawn has been
picked up the D5 bond has been picked up
and it's beautiful tactics again the
back rank the back rank is there per
match Magnus has given his opponents one
chance for alireza it has been a
difficult game so far any hope Magnus
has taken the decision to move the
bishop to f Drive Rook to F4 is a big
threat on the board the Queen doesn't
have too many squares yeah the black
queen looks really really active but she
might well be trapped uh farouzia needs
something active now
I'm struggling there's also a big threat
of uh Knight takes bishop and then the
bishop swooping in as well
what is he thinking about if not and
it's he's played Bishop A3 but he took
quite a bit of time before making this
decision so Magnus Carlsen can go safe
with Queen E1 are there any other
attacking idea and he does it David
knows Magnus
and the Queens are off the board no
checkmates uh at least not for now but
white still with this extra Pawn the two
Pawn combo in the center I thought it's
two points up I forgot black captured on
H4 a bit earlier but now this kind of
massive pieces that we see uh in the
center this tension unfortunately for
frugier it's hard to deal with uh
White's Pieces Just coordinates so well
with their pawns and okay it just Rook
to B8 looks like a pseudo active move
trying to maybe uh come into the white
position with that Rook later on the
open file that looks like a pretty
pretty juicy way of doing it actually on
the board yeah two pawns up now for
Magnus Carlson
I think this one was missed by it for
Asia unfortunately that again it's just
tactics working in White's favor because
he is the better coordination the better
centralization
and this could spell the end
yeah 10 seconds
he needs to make a movie uh four seconds
okay he takes it with how much time did
he have on the clock because it's a
three seconds barely any time oh wow
Magnus is just saying okay I'm gonna
just have the draw in hand in case I
need it right is that you know
that's actually a really safety first
idea from Magnus I mean he played this
really quickly but I mean uh because
it's enough he only a draw is the same
as a win right so but I mean okay he
loses he's lost a lot of his Advantage
Magnus from doing this and black does
have the a pawn I mean fuja is gonna
play this out it isn't oh not no but the
key might be checked me into a mating
net is going to get caged he need four G
four maybe four and now he's the case he
has to go H5 the problem is if he went
the other way I think it's at least a
Perpetual check right for white so you
have to if you're in a must win
situation try this way one second for
future again if you made it with under
one second only stopped the Jack only
way to stop the Perpetual oh Rock H5 was
a Checkmate now the e-pawn is running
through blacks Rook is too far offside
and for Asia leans back yeah in
disappointment he's gonna resign he does
it
resigns Magnus Carlsen wrapping it up in
three games it has been a disappointing
day for alirez